okay guys we want to talk about what is ketosis
a little bit more on this topic ketosis is this
when you avoid consuming glucose or sugar for
10 to 12 hours your body will then start to make
ketones okay ketones are basically the byproduct
of fat burning and you can even test yourself on
ketones there's these strips you can get at the
drugstore called ketone strips and you check your
urine it'll be like in a different shade of purple
so if it's really dark purple it's like major
ketosis if it's light purple it's minor ketosis
so you can check to see if you're burning fat
or not the thing that you need to know is when
we convert our body from sugar to fat it takes
between three days to two weeks up to six weeks
depending how long you've been around your body
and sugar in other words your body has to create
new machinery in the cells so it's very similar
to let's say you're running your house on coal to
heat it right and then we're going to have to run
it on electric fuel electric heating I'm sorry not
fuel you're going to have to install new machinery
hook up wires to be able to run your body the
same thing with running you're buying a fat fuel
this is like diesel fuel or coal it's very dirty
this is like solar or electric cars very clean no
waste quiet so to do this it could take anywhere
from one week to six weeks okay so in the process
I'm going to be showing you what to do because
if you don't do this correctly you could end
up with a lot of issues okay so we're going to
show you how to do it healthily but but here's
the thing when we run our body on a ketones it's
much more stable with your blood sugars you won't
have the highs and lows anymore so you're going
to be very level-headed your brain is going to
love it your your memories going to be sharper
you lot you you'll just be right there all the
time better focus more efficient fuel less dirty
less complications ketones are the original fuel
source it's the original fuel of the brain our
bodies long ago ran an ketones why because we
could necessarily eat all the sugar that we had we
didn't eat three meals a day or six meals a day we
didn't eat the junk food so our bodies originally
were designed to run on ketones not sugar it's
only till very recently that we've been eating
sugar so we're going to go back to what your
body is designed to to run on and it's it's much
better I will never go back to running my body and
sugar because once you feel feel the benefits you
won't go back now the other thing is that ketosis
pretext protein in other words when you go on this
eating plan it's you're not going to have to worry
about your body eating up your own protein that's
only when you have insulin so your body's not
going to convert protein into fat so people are
just concerned am I going to lose muscle mass no
no you're going to gain muscle mass your ligaments
tendons collagen is going to get better now what's
going to happen you can lose a lot of weight
with this program the thing is that let's say you
didn't lose a lot of weight doesn't necessarily
you didn't burn fat but the best indicator because
what's happening is you could actually gain
muscle mass and lose fat and actually weigh
the same because muscle weighs more than fat so
the best indicator to know it's working is the
ketone strips or a tape measure around your waist
at the very outer portion so you check the
waist every week and you can measure and see
how many inches you lost that's the ultimate
measurement of success okay because who cares
what you weigh if you can get a flat stomach
so the problem is it's going to be very expensive
you have to get rid of all your old clothes your
old belt your old suits your shirts get all new
clothes it's going to be very very expensive you
can blame me okay so when you do this also your
get rid of a lot of excess fluid now sugar always
follows fluid and or fluid follows sugar so if
you get rid of all the sugar you're going to get
rid of the fluid as well okay so when you get rid
of fluid you're going to lose you might lose up
to I don't know ten pounds in the first week some
people lose ten pounds that's fluid the most fat
that you can burn per week is two pounds that's
in a healthy body anything more it's just fluid so
anyway I wanted to kind of explain the timeframe
it takes what we're trying to do we're trying to
switch over to ketones it's a better fuel source
and let's let's show you the next next video